a Shadowhunters fans I'm Liana Galera
and I'm so thrilled because right now
I'm with four of our finest
Shadowhunters fellows Dom Harry Alberto
and Isiah hi guys how's it going
thank you all so much for taking time
out of your schedules to come in and
chat about the final season of
Shadowhunters we're just a few days away
how are y'all feeling knowing that this
is now officially the beginning of the
end for so long the anticipation push
back and then we got the last two
episodes to round everything out well I
have a lot of fun surprises for all the
fans and for you fellas today so let's
just jump right into one of my favorite
questions to ask what did you guys steal
from set what as you really how many
eyeliner pencils did you still know that
I got like the bust from yeah I didn't
steal it so we just handed it to me and
never took it back so I just had people
sign it somebody handed me six leather
jackets and four pairs of jeans how
about you know I think that these boots
were looking pretty cool told you that
Jason boots they've had some where I've
had these for a minute and then I say I
was given and then then didn't was never
asked to give back same like there was
some leather jackets that I have and
then I have my sword and some things
from my room which was tricky because
that was the last day and they'd nailed
everything shot so we had like that's
not what I was going to say at all and
then what I really like is they gave me
one of the last slates from
the last shot that we did they be camera
gave me there there did you keep your
face I did I mean to someone else which
I was fine because I never used them so
you know change for Joel yes we have 12
more episodes of Shadowhunters coming
away I know that the fans are so excited
but I know you guys can't give away too
many details so just tell us which
episode number are you most excited for
the fans to see for your character tens
good tens very close I'll just pick the
number between 11 and 22
I was I was making a joke it clearly
didn't land 12 yeah like it starts with
11 though that's it starts with it yeah
it starts with 11
oh so then then 20 would be my favorite
yeah 20 which yeah 10 2010 we're all
counting sorry you guys crapped this
quite a bit ago so I understand if you
need to refresh your memory a little bit
and freeform just gave us an amazing new
trailer for 3b of Shadowhunters so I
thought we would all take a look at it
together so you guys can watch it here
and the fans gonna watch you watch a
trailer
and the flesh resurrection got back my
real face
feels good to be back
oh I was hoping you can do that fuel
it's this darkness it's growing to
overcome your demons you have to face
them I'm looking at all the way to the
pack needs right here in front of it I
won't lose you come back to me Simon you
have so much more to listen
I love you until I die it is my honor to
pronounce you one oh yeah this is it
sorry somewhat out of your side I'll see
you in hell this is who I am
join me do it wow this CGI team have
done an increasing focus yeah you
mentioned one you were watching it
you're like spoiler alert tell us again
which part you were well there is so
much that is in store for fans this
season as you're looking back at this I
couldn't help but see that it seems like
there's a wedding coming our way what do
you guys have to say about that it was
time we're gonna take it for a few fan
questions right now we pulled them out
on Twitter and we got some really great
responses from you guys so at no watches
TV says it looks like Luke Simon and
Jace are all gonna deal with Clarys
death in totally different ways are we
gonna see them rely on each other and
work together etc the cold the cold
thing the cold thing that was a couple
of days remember that yeah I know from
my point of view that Jace relies on
Luke quite heavily for support and then
also the ideas and the passion to to
bring back someone that we that we all
care about individually so Luke
especially early on in the seasons
really really runs the show kind of
thing well he's got to get his baby girl
back right yeah Simon is kind of he
isolated himself from the entire world
so luckily Izzy's the person that he
ends up
having to kind of figure all this out
with and see what his plan is which is a
really great question from Kela
underscore Murray 27 says our Suzy fans
going to be happy we've been waiting so
long
so Simon and is the of course were such
a significant relationship in the book
and now we're finally gonna see this
relationship play out on screen what was
what were your thoughts going into this
new relationship well I mean we always
knew that it was coming we always wanted
to make sure that we did it the right
way especially because it's supposed to
be in the books what they did really
well is that it was like they met at the
right time when they and it kind of
speaks to that whole idea that timing is
important and now Russia you have you
date other people to kind of learn about
who you can be and what you want and
then you might find that person that's
like ready for you when you're ready for
them and it's so I'm glad we got to
build it that way and we took a lot of
care and had a lot of fun with it
and I do think that the Suzy shippers
that have been waiting so long will be
very happy with just the whole
relationship this season just how we
that we get to be closer as people we're
in more positions where we have to be
working together you guys are ready
we're ready from dancing and training
Malik on Twitter says Magnus is now lost
his magic and his place in the shadow
world and eager to know what
consequences it will have on his
relationship with the Shadowhunters
squad with the down world leaders with
other warlocks and with Alec Dave is a
question well now he has to actually
cook breakfast for himself yeah that's I
mean that the little things I think that
says what they start dealing with like
even putting the whole makeup on and but
I think for helping everyone else just
like he's used to having this process
that he's like I'm gonna use my magic
I'm gonna go in and do my thing now he's
almost like like helpless and he does he
can't really do much so he has to learn
how to do what the Shadowhunters do
without their powers that they have
so I think it becomes interesting and it
also puts a strain on the relationship
with with Alec and I know you guys don't
like to hear that guys I mean you have
to have the downs in order to have the
ups
yeah so I think we can go through a few
tough times if good times are ahead but
what the great part of it is Alec really
steps up and really helps Magnus kind of
come into the real world where Scarlett
Russell wants to know what is the thing
you guys have found that you have in
common with your character she also adds
love you guys Isaiah what do you have
most in common with Luke six leather
jackets yeah I think probably just being
a father figure that's probably the
closest thing other than occasional
Saturday night yes Alberto I've been
playing a lot of Mario Kart lately
playing might be a bit of a misnomer
he's losing a lot of Mary I don't know I
don't think I have a huge amount in
common with with Jace I think the people
that I have in my life that I keep
pretty close and the people that I trust
I love with with my entirety and I think
I have that in common with Jace but the
rest like I had a really happy family
life and like I know who my brothers and
sisters are nobody's tried to kill me
fighting skills I
yeah I mean what's the trailer um I mean
that's a hard one I think the what I do
share is kind of I guess maybe the
compassion of like Magnus he's very
compassionate and just always bringing
people into
to help them up as much as they can as
much as you can and that's one of the
things that qualities of Magnus that I
that I really love especially being I'm
not that old
in the sense of hundreds of years old
but for someone who's like lived that
long and to be able to still have that
side of them I think it's it's really
special make sure that wise well I'm so
glad that I was able to get all four of
you fellows in to studio today we are in
LA for those who are wondering but I
wanted to reach out to one very special
fan and and have them send a message to
you guys
so we'll go ahead and take a look at
this special fan video gonna be who's it
gonna be it's made a little upset that
you found time to do an interview
without me it'll ask you a question
why is that like like what your favorite
character I want to be in the most New
York I wanna be in the middle of Central
Park
put on a beanie that's question why is
Alec your favorite character of course
that was the question why is it your
favorite
why is he my favorite cuz Matt daddario
plays him why is my favorite I think he
shoots bows and arrows I think that's
pretty neat I think Matt's level of
disdain and Alix level of disdain for
just random things are perfectly in sync
oh that is true yeah I bet Matt didn't
see this coming to bring it back to to
the Magnus of all he shot it oh yes yes
that is yeah you know and it's you know
what's funny is that like you're almost
someone who's just like a cold like he's
very like like Alex Alex is very cool
and then to have
that side brought out of him isn't it's
like beautiful so I mean like I think
that no I don't know we thought you were
gonna stick with the bully grow like he
was just he kind of just was closed off
to everything yeah and to see the growth
in the past couple of season I think
hasn't really spent yeah and all kind of
that that idea of that role model that
person who's in this position where you
feel like they have to have a lot of
armor and that they can carry that
strength while taking that armor off
layer by layer pretty cool thank you
fans love this show so much and as we
reach this final chapter and you guys
have wrapped up and you'd said your
goodbyes obviously you are all still
close you guys are playing Mario Kart
together again no don't you as you guys
were leaving like it honestly it's made
me think about like saying goodbye to
like your friends in high school and of
course in high school you have
superlatives so we're gonna play a
little game called shadow hunter
superlatives where we are going to have
you guys kind of put your fellow
co-stars on blast and some of them are
gonna be some sort classic high school
superlatives some of them are going to
be more shadow hunters base
so first up who was the biggest predator
on set you've already put the camera on
me that's not what is the best prank
that you pulled the worst one I did and
I felt bad about this not so much
anymore cuz he's played his finger in my
ear but I put you remember the trash can
thing dude yes that was rough so I we
had like an old like gross trash can
outside and I put it in Alberto's
trailer thinking that he was gonna like
find it right away
and be like oh this is gross and then
get rid of it but then he got called to
work like right after watching is there
for like four hours
it was just like heating up this like
morbid smells really grim and then he
takes me like six hours later like why
would you do this to me and I'm like
wait how have you just found it
did you lock someone's like like keep
off I take cap to the trailer yeah got
hurt attach the trailer to people and
then the headshot it's like fun you
might put them on yeah we printed out
like 200 of our own headshots and I put
them all over Alberto's tray they were
like under his toilet seat his drawers
but that one backfired as well because
we ended up I think about those trailers
at the end of the season got sent to
someone else and I'm like there's no way
he's found all of my headshot someone's
like opening their toilet and being like
who is this who is this so that one was
pretty rough who on set was the biggest
life of the party yeah like when he
tells a story or like one of those
really long jokes that he gets into yeah
and he does with the hands and the
characters and stuff but the jokes has
he done that joke where he just has his
long joke that goes like 20 minutes and
there's no punch of no punch line yeah
so you're sitting there listening to
this toy funny when he's a good
storyteller because you're jord like
intrude with what he's saying oh yeah
he's doing a lot of this yeah and you
include the whole time with what he's
saying
next up who would be best dressed
I mean Isaiah you always look sharp I
can't take that title though I'd have to
go
[Music]
[Laughter]
best eyes Dom Dom has different eyes I
wouldn't say best eyes I think that's
very sweet of all of these I'm doing
years worthless company in school next
up best hair Oh cats go good hair yeah I
like Alicia yeah Alicia's go good hair
yeah here you got the swoop I got I got
that thing like like the win
is always blowing on one way I got me
and just like Dario's doesn't move like
on school however you want to interpret
it oh okay that's a tricky one like this
is a real throw someone which season
which season come on Malik is pretty
cute what about what about personal
couples again which season no okay I'm
out of it next up the biggest stunt
superstar that goes to that has to be
Darrin and Dean Darrin McGuire and Dean
Cove who were asked ton coordinates and
I'm sure that's not a question you were
asking but these two were just the most
incredible guys we ever worked would I
mean I'm sure these guys agree with me
back yeah you know I just speak for
myself but unbelievable they had us
doing some of the most ridiculous things
that they haven't done with TV actors
before and there was no point in my
career on Shadowhunters that I felt
unsafe while they were looking after me
but I would say like even like DOM and
Kat they had to do I think like the mold
yes cats count was wildly impressive yes
that she had to learn and do your growth
about it never mind there's the ones
that was most likely to flood their
lines
you're pretty good Matt but Matt when he
does it it just like no one can keep it
together he can't be together you seen
the bloopers right I think it also
matters like everyone's really solid and
then it's after a certain time and
amount of
that's what the other day we how cold it
was
yes chew your tongue most likely to be a
little late yeah like what do you mean
like like them going like alright
everybody on set or actually coming onto
the stage I'm pretty late coming onstage
I don't throw myself under the bus but
it's just cuz I have so much stuff to
put on yeah and like and I can't put
like certain chains together and I can't
button certain things I'm just sitting
there waiting and they're like where's
Harry I'm like last one is who's most
likely to keep the Shadowhunters group
chat going babies it's cool to keep that
like together and then now to have the
premiere you guys have probably the most
passionate fan base that I've ever
encountered in all four years of
covering TV they're still raising
billboards they still so badly want to
see this show continue do you have a
message to the Shadowhunters fandom it's
really inspiring it sees like the
resilience and then their love for the
show so it's it's it's I think it's I
can speak for all of us has really
warmed our hearts um you know because
everyone worked really really hard on
the show and you know we love these
characters so it's just so awesome to
see that there's big a large group of
people that that really love it just as
much or even more and which is really
inspiring to see yeah you know I'd be
really cool I mean I know we can't go do
it even four or five
anything but they did just like one ox
you know like yeah they used to do with
Gilligan's Island
they just have like a one-off like I
just don't like like a like a two-hour
two-hour movie you know you know or
people just come back and just like
domesticating and watching like binge
watching something just something about
I don't know why you ask that question
just now I thought of like Hamilton and
heard George Washington say goodbye and
in the way that they do it is he did it
for a reason to be like no this is how
you have to do it so it continues and
for our show to be ending this way with
that fan support is the way you want to
go out like that's a way to say goodbye
like yeah we have this 12 episodes
coming out everyone's been waiting for
it we're pretty happy with it
we can't wait to share it they're
excited it's a yeah yeah you know I
think it's well said it's especially
instead of like oh wait what he's back
you know when you all read that series
finale script what was your initial
reaction I can't believe it's it's a big
part of like you know like we you know
we literally blood sweat tears went into
this for for three years we we gave
everything of ourselves to make this
show as as good as it could possibly be
and yeah it was it was emotional and
there was so there are some very
uplifting parts in the last couple of
scripts and then there's some really sad
parts and those are mixed with your
emotions as someone who is you know
having to say goodbye to something
that's been such a profound part of our
life the table readers definitely table
read was we've ever done that's a hard
question
without giving away spoilers yeah
everyone came then we got the time like
really spend in individual moments on
sets going to different places in the
studio being like oh remember this
bathroom used to be our gym it smelled
terrible and had like three things but
we worked out therefore proved it's the
White House it's like to scale model I'm
doing everything wait what shadow world
to White House I want to say thank you
all so much for joining me it's been
such a thrill to chat with you guys and
to cover this show and I'm so excited to
see where this final season takes us
because the final season of
Shadowhunters premieres on february 25th
on freeform with 12 all-new episodes
thank you all so much for tuning in and
we'll see you next time bye guys
[Music]